le village est construit au sommet de la
vallée de la loue qui domine la rivière
apprécié l'été des touristes comme elle
l'était déjà du peintre gustave courbet
c'est un des joyaux de la vallée de la
loue les mots sont forts mais c'est vrai
que le village est posée dans un écrin
de verdure et c'est vrai que quand on
descend la départementale 67 et qu'on
aperçoit notre village en fond de vallée
on peut être que séduit par ce village
des paysages puis aussi un patrimoine
historique on voit derrière nous avec
cette église vous dit tout à fait oui on
a vraiment un patrimoine architectural
et un patrimoine ancien au sein de ce
village qui fait que aujourd'hui je
pense que que ce village peut faire
partie du village préféré des français
un ancien prieuré dont l'église
saint-laurent reste un des vestiges les
plus significatifs de l'histoire du
village une architecture mise en valeur
par ses paysages escarpés
caractéristiques des gorges de noailles
c'est le seul pont du village à cet
impôt qui est classée c'est vrai qu'on a
quand même vu quelques magnifiques avec
labeaume la cascade de 6 ratures et puis
là cette rivière magnifique de première
catégorie pour les amoureux de la pêche
des pêcheurs accueillis par des
habitants très attachés à leur commune
mouty hautepierre qui à cet autre
particularité de disposer encore d'une
vie sociale qui attire beaucoup de
jeunes familles au village ou
d'événements qui sont organisées
tout au long de l'année en fête pour les
enfants les mamans et les papas s'est
pas seulement des jolies pierres c'est
pas se mouiller ya vraiment une vis dans
ce village c'est vrai ouais ça bouge pas
mal
c'est une vraie vie ce village avec une
vraie dynamique et ça c'est ce qui fait
la fierté quand on est maire d'une
commune commun comme outil hautepierre